-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor and comedian
you know from his work
as Ali G., Bruno, and Borat.
He wrote, produced, and starre
in "Borat Subsequent Moviefilm,"
for which he received
an Oscar nomination
and WGA award for
Best Adapted Screenplay.
He is also nominated for a
Oscar for Best Supporting Acto
for his performance
as Abbie Hoffman
in "The Trial of the Chicago 7."
Let's take a look.
-You know why
you're on trial here?
-We carried certain ideas
across state lines.
Not machine guns
or drugs or little girls.
Ideas.
When we crossed from New Yor
to New Jersey to Pennsylvani
to Ohio to Illinois,
we had certain ideas.
And for that, we were gassed
beaten, arrested,
and put on trial.
-Please welcome to the sho
Sacha Baron Cohen.
How are you, Sacha?
-Hi, good.
How's it going, Seth?
-It's going very well.
It's incredible to me
not only how wonderful
both these performances are,
but the fact that you were
doing them simultaneously
is shocking to me
because it's -- obviously,
they're two very different sets.
One is very controlled, an
then, of course, you have Borat.
-Yes. I mean,
on the set of "Chicago 7,"
you can go to craft services
and, you know,
you can go to a trailer.
On the set of "Borat,"
you're basically running awa
from the police.
So, you meet in between.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, it's so funny,
because, of course, that's wha
Abbie Hoffman
goes through in real life.
And it's what you put yourself
through as an actor as Borat
You know, Abbie Hoffman
was someone who used clownin
to sort of
make political points.
Very different from Borat,
obviously,
in what they were aiming to do
but there
are some similarities there.
-Yeah, I mean --
I almost found Abbie
this really
inspirational character.
I first read about him
when I was in university
when I was about 20.
And he was really hilarious,
brilliantly clever, and --
but fundamentally,
like, this really brave,
courageous activist who,
you know, actually was ready
to die to fight injustice,
which is not a very funny thin
to say on a late-night show,
but I've done it.
-Well, it's interesting, though,
because I do feel like
this "Borat" was certainly mor
political than the last one.
And in a way,
you were putting yourself
in fairly dangerous situations
You must realize, like,
there is some parallel now
to what Abbie Hoffman
was doing a long time ago.
-Well, I never really wanted
to do another Borat movie,
and then,
Donald Trump came along,
and I got increasingly angry
with some of the things
that were going on --
the Muslim ban, et cetera.
And then, it's coming up
to the election,
and I felt I needed to put
the gray suit on again just to
you know, put out somethin
to show that I didn't agree.
And we really just wanted it
to come out before the election.
So the whole crew put themselves
through crazy experiences
and put themselves at real risk.
-So, you know, obviously,
you have just
the logistical challenges
of something like CPAC,
which I want to ask about
in a minute,
and then you have the challenges
of writing a script.
But, of course,
the core of Borat
is this performance
and this character you become.
And you went to clowning school.
Was that actually in France?
-That was a French teacher
called Philippe Gaulier.
And luckily, it was in London.
People would fly
from around the world.
There were people from Australia
flown to -- to study with him.
And then, basically,
the first thing you would do
is you put some clown music,
you put on your red nose,
go around the room.
If he hit his drum,
you would have to sit down
And that was it.
That was the end
of your exercise.
And you'd have people who'
flown in from Australia,
the clown music goes,
stops the clown music,
they start speaking,
and he hits his drum,
'cause they're not funny.
And they would burst into tear
and hate him.
-Very sad.
Just sad to think of anyon
crying in their
full clown costume.
-Exactly. Exactly.
Sad clown.
-Is this a -- is this a clow
teacher who is proud of the work
that you have done in the year
since you were under
his tutelage?
-Well, I'm still
in contact with him,
and I'll call him up,
and I'll go, "What do you think?
How was that?"
and he'll often go,
"That was [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
"It was not good.
You are not funny.
We did not like this character."
You know, so...
Yeah, it keeps -- he's very good
at keeping me down.
-Is it true that,
even before Ali G.,
you worked on a kids show?
-It was a --
I was bizarrely,
given my lack of personality
the host of a show.
Admittedly,
it was for teenagers,
but I wanted to get out
of the job and be a comedian
But it was --
I didn't know anyone in London
who had that job.
I didn't even know any actors.
So I basically started
doing these little character
live on the TV show.
So I would go out
and shoot beforehand.
And the idea was they'd play i
and react to what was going on
And one of the characters
actually was Borat.
So, first time I ever
took him out
was at a fox-hunting rally
in London
outside the House of Parliament.
It was a bunch of members
of the upper class going out
to say that
they should keep fox hunting
because it's an important
English tradition.
And I went out and basically
pretended to be from Moldova
and I was, "Hello.
I'm from Moldova telebisk.
In my country, we hunt Jews.
We give them a head start,
and then we hunt them.
You think we should do it here?"
And they'd say,
"Well, I suppose if it was -
if it was a fair start, at least
20 or 30 minutes, then yes."
And, yeah, so that was
the birth of Ali G. and Borat,
and eventually,
I left that kids show.
Obviously, everyone
at the kids show hated it.
By the way, when I put those -
when I actually put those things
on the TV show,
I immediately got brought in
to the head of the show,
and he said, "Do that agai
and you are fired."
And, in fact,
they not only fired me,
they shut down
the entire channel.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's a nice legacy.